barristan has been uh
a kingsguard
for 40 years you know that's how he
defines his life he long ago gave up any
hope of marriage
uh he he forsook his uh his claim to
his father's lands and let that pass to
uh to a brother
um for the honor of serving in the
kingsguard who served for life
um and
he was the king's guard to the mad king
and he was wounded fighting for prince
rhaegar on the trident
uh but he was such an honorable night
that robert uh
pardoned him for supporting the
targaryens and
asked him to become the lord commander
of robert's king god which he
accepted because that was the only life
he knew
and then joffrey and the lannisters have
discarded this entire tradition they've
essentially thrown away everything
that he thought was life was about by
dismissing him from the
from the kingsguard
as long as the starks were strong i
don't think he was actually planning
this when he marched south
but you know when presented with
opportunity he would do anything to
strengthen
his own position and strengthen house
bolton and weaken his
his enemies um and he did so it several
times but he was a he's a cold and
rational and calculating sort of guy if
if rob had continued to win i think he
would have continued to be
loyal and uh you know if robert not lost
the phrase and the car starks
and it's and it seemed like he might
come out of this bolton would have been
right there by his side
the unsullied that dany encounters in
astapor
these are the prime unsullied she's
buying an entire army
full of them
and they are absolutely obedient which
is the big thing they won't revolt
against you they won't turn against you
as self swords will
you can buy a sell sword and pay him
money and then when he thinks you're
losing or when someone offers him more
money he'll go over the unsullied will
not
do that their their training makes that
absolutely unthinkable to to them
they have nothing they live for the unit
but they are very potent soldiers and
for someone intending to go to war
having a core of unsullied infantry uh
at the heart of your army
um is quite something
and certainly in any battle in westeros
if danny can get them back to westeros
uh an unsullied infantry would give her
an immense advantage over the
the feudal levees of the westerosi lords
second sons are a mercenary company
who sell their services uh under
contracts to anyone who wants to hire
them be it a
a free city a slaver city a lord
who wants to take over his city
uh someone who just wants to pillage and
loot
someone who wants to cross dangerous
territory and needs a strong escort
there are a number of these uh
mercenary companies or free companies as
they call themselves
uh in essos um you know the
the nine free cities uh tyrosh and
pentos and mir and all that
do not have great military traditions so
they
they although they have their own
soldiers and their own militias and
you know people who their city guards
will defend their walls
when they're fighting wars they prefer
to hire mercenaries to fight the wars
for them
this is something that derives from
actual medieval customs that i've uh
used for the for the books uh dark ages
customs actually when
when the world was a very dangerous
place
and if you showed up at uh someone's
house and they took you in and offered
you hospitality
it was expected that the the laws of
hospitality the guest right
uh ruled
and under the guest right a host cannot
harm his guest
and a guest cannot harm his host and
it's really
uh a tradition uh a law
that is very essential in in
kind of savage environments where
there's a lot of dangers in the wild and
all that because
you don't want to let someone in under
your roof if you think they're going to
murder them
in the night and you don't want to
shelter with someone who might say oh
this guy has nice horses and
and a lot of money so let's just kill
him and all that so the laws of
hospitality became very very sacred and
certainly that's true in westeros where
particularly in the north
where the laws of hospitality are very
strong you